[Musique]
la vie si tous kankan est astucieux
peine
à chauny cette discussion le plus
sérieux ça va vite à jouer il suffit de
vouloir revenir à un ami
[Musique]
est un peu qu'est ce que c'est que ça y
est tu as ta chatte a vu ses ninjas
j'ai vu signer une lorraine mais je vois
pas bien le rapport et ben moi je danse
tu veux que je te fasse des claquettes
non pas plus pas de menace menace parce
que les claquettes c'est pas facile ces
actes attaque
atari sa version des claquettes voila
voila tu as fait ni ne me donnait des
coups avec ton parapluie là où il fait
part à puis c'est une ombrelle
à cette époque là oui parce que je
t'emmène dans un pays chaud allons bon
voilà où est ce que tu va m'emmener
derrière la carte à la carte ici oui
nous jouons tout de suite à l' ange
blond tout de suite au jeu de la
géographie une carte du pays
quelque part c'est logique oui c'est du
côté du col chic c'est chic et pas cher
alors et là nous avons le drapeau du
pays et le façon de dire bonjour dans la
langue de ce pays tu as tu veux mon
nombre et non ça va moi je supporte
allègrement qu'est ce que je viens faire
là bas tu en fais ce que tu veux c'est
pas mon problème
alors voilà à c'est une île déjà c'est
unique
c'est une île ça si tu me lis je crois
même que on l'appelle en général la
grande île il semble enfin c'est si ma
mémoire ne me trompe pas nous avons là
le drapeau de ce pays regardez bien et
beau et boa il est bon là vous avez dû
lui que tous les dires
j'aime bien parce que il ya une bande
verticale et le bande horizontale ça
j'aime bien la verticale et blanches
croyez lacets rouges et la sévère et
enfin bon jour dans la langue d'un pays
aux cépages lissar avis c'est pas joli
fava c'est moi qui l'ait bonjour sans
arrêt là bas manao iron man down à
manawan nattes ou encore oui je peux
dire deux fois prix bien sûr vous avez
devinez de quel pays il s'agit la grande
île et bats la grande île c'est
madagascar
c'est la grande île de madagascar avec
sa capitale qui s'appelait tananarive et
je crois qu'elle a changé un peu de noms
saanen arrive ça va il cesse un genre de
choses qui n'arrivent
mais je me demande si c'est pas
antananarivo maintenant je crois j'ai lu
ça quelque part
enfin nous l'appelons toujours
tananarive c'est le nom auquel nous
sommes habitués et manao à roanne n'a
cessé ces jolies au revoir on ne sait
pas comment ça se dit c'est dommage
si le choix et non d'une autre vie de
cette île bas il y avait tamatave amat
sur la côte oui tamatave qui était
inquiété le grand port de lille je crois
et matériels et ben alors au revoir
alors je vais devoir le jardin j'ai
peut-être prendre ça quand même parce
que ça va le gêner
oui surtout que je crois qu'il pleut
dans le genre oui bah alors jusqu'au
maroc attention ne s'agit pas de
plaisanter avec ça non plus à l'est
alors les enfants
oui oui on est là pour me rappeler en
vitesse que si le bois connaît mais le
prix à ses amis oui tu viens oui ça rit
ça y est
pas de folie un pas de folie mais alors
du jeu à la racine et toi immédiatement
sans plus attendre en peluche harry
parce que oui c'est vrai ça va oui bon
ok je verrai je commence le point commun
est oui là j'aimerais bien là qui comme
un bon je suis bien alors moi tout le
monde me connaît
si vous êtes un voyageur enfin c'est à
dire si vous prenez le train ou l'avion
ou le bateau ou le métro mais pas la
voiture dont ça les automobilistes
ignorent et vous avez intérêt à ne pas
vous tromper sur mon compte car sinon
vous risquez rien d'avoir des ennuis
avec le contrôle euros alors j'existe
généralement sous deux formes
différentes
alors vous précisé l'une ou l'autre de
ces formes suivant votre goût du confort
et est aussi suivant votre porte monnaie
et si vous préférez mon aspect le plus
économique je ne vous en voudrez pas et
je vous fait voyager aussi vite et aussi
tranquillement voilà bon à toi même tu
sais que je suis aujourd'hui
et quelque chose que j'ai naturellement
quoi ah bon oui c'est une chose qui ne
s'expliquent pas facilement qui ne
s'apprend pas on l'a où on l'a pas c'est
tout et toi tu là et moi je vais vous
allez me dire à quoi est ce que cela
soit fait je vous répondrai on a une
certaine manière de marcher de parler de
s'habiller qui fait qu'on ne peut pas
passer inaperçu quoi les autres vous
remarquez vous regarde avec un sentiment
d'admiration et de respect
fabrice moi je pense que tu vois ce que
je veux dire
je crois avoir trouvé bush moussu a son
mot à dire
ah bah ouais moi moi moi je suis très
connu de tous les enfants qui vont à
l'école tous depuis les petits de 4 ans
qui font leurs débuts à la maternelle
jusqu'aux grands qui vont à appeler du
poly politique peut lire au lit des
cliniques rurales ce ça c'est difficile
à dire polytechnique oui je peux avoir
toutes les tailles
forcément puisque je peux rassembler
aussi bien une dizaine d'enfants qu'une
cinquantaine de grands arrêts et et chez
moi on apprend tout l'histoire l'anglais
les sciences naturelles l'orthographe ou
fréquenter cet endroit
enfin on apprend tout quoi le le dessin
tout tout tout tu vois ce que je veux
dire
ah oui oui je crois bon 3ème et un
départ commun tu veux parler des
économies que j'ai trouvé à dire oui oui
oui tu veux que tous qu encore et encore
alors toutes les économies où là la
physique n'est là pour casser sa
tirelire et belges écoute alors j'y vais
attention toi tout con con tu es la
classe de chemin de fer des trois avions
haut et de la première ou la deuxième
classe doit bel bel tu as de la classe
allemande avoir de la classe à wii et
enfin pouces ou sur wii et tech que vous
connaissez bien là la classe la casse où
vont les enfants des écoles publiques en
oui aller en classe
voilà est tous contents et ruiner
complètement avait tout perdu je suis
écoeuré à ces normes je suis écoeuré
et c'est encore plus amis je m'en vais
avec ma classe au revoir ma chère elle
bel au revoir mon chien fabricant
d'outils
quand vous aurez fini de regarder bell
bell vous pourrez peut-être continuer à
jouer avec moi m'a dit don't touch mou
sur quatre roues dérogent port et s'ils
veulent comme tes amis rapidos nash et
rapide où ce tu permets une petite
seconde
je suis occupé avec pousse aussi oui oh
oui oui oui
tout à l'air tout à leur rapide bon
alors fabrice c'est bien nous notre
petit jeu
oui on y va tu vas au tableau absolue
d'habitude bien je sais que tu n'as pas
oublié ton marqueur thomas marie jeanne
meyer alors voyait très bien
alors cette fois ci c'est un mot un
cette lettre ou sept
on commence par un 1 2 3 4 5 et la
lettre et la dernière un ace alors alors
j'ai un animal aller et bah oui c est un
animal bien c'est un ami à nous ils
veulent parlant d' high court pas ét é
qui quoi qui rend oui multiples grands
batteurs rient ils rentrent et est-ce
qu'il sera temps il va vite
noro non pas très vite il va très
lentement oui oui oui assez lentement
oui oui oui il est assez impressionnant
ah bon et oui les gros noms il roule
jamais pourquoi la rationnant il
impressionne quand même que tu que je te
donne une lettre supplémentaire pour t d
un peu ça j'aimerais bien oui alors la
troisième laiterie
la troisième c'est un air à bon c'est
pas du tout ce à quoi je pensais que les
tv qu'il était impressionnant parce
qu'il a des il a des petits pains s'il a
deux pinces ce que l'avancé ce que c'est
c'est un animal qui qui vient s qui vit
dans l'eau oui oui horrible viroleau
évident l'ont mis dans l'eau dans la mer
non non il vit en eau douce dans les
rivières alors oui un et rivières alors
atteint on est bien une mais alors je me
demande si tu aurais eu le toupet de
vouloir parler de l'écrevisse et ben
voila tu as trouvé que tu écris
naturellement pas que j'écris eux c est
eux veulent s est produit
ça nous paraît bien tout cancan 1 616
moi je crois que c'est ça oui ça existe
un risque comme ça et vous seriez tous
les deux recalés d'une maternelle est
renvoyé on le voit la voilà comment on
écrit encore écrevisses n'avez pas honte
v i 2 s o 1 voilà à rome une écran apple
on voit pas
j'ai comme place et commence à observer
deux aînés et oui on peut pas peut pas
tout savoir mais pas tous américains
tuent parce que tu sais est ce que tu
sais que les écrevisses lente arrive
l'hiver elles creusent des trous dans
les berges à bourg s'abriter mais oui et
et plus l'hiver va être froid oui plus
les trous qu'elle creuse sont profonds 1
c'est un bon truc sain pour prévoir le
temps tu pourras pas certainement là
c'est formidable moi vos smoothies tout
cas encore ne restent pas comme ça à
t'endormir gentiment n'est ce pas
pendant que ton petit camarade travail
on n'a pas le droit on est ébloui les
télés bluey partout val d'armance avoir
retrouvons l'éblouissante belle ait du
talent elle aussi joué avec moi que toi
[Musique]
papa papa louis qui fait donc compléter
les syllabes que je ne commence pas par
une note de musique
oui et toutes ces notes te donnerons
l'air de la chanson dans le double fond
il s'est en tout cas si la cokerie mais
je ne me suis pas fait bon bah tant
mieux qu'ils nous avons eu peur puis la
parole
enfin enfin rapido alors donc je raconte
mon histoire
oui c'est une histoire qui dure très
longtemps moins une semaine et même elle
ne pourrait elle pourrait ne jamais
s'arrêter
imagine que bomata un groupe de trois
personnes se présentent at on tout
missile d'homicide pas attendre les six
mois il y a à monsieur une dalle est un
jeune garçon l'essonne il frappe et
comme la porte ne s'ouvre pas il un seul
les un système injuste mais rien à faire
la porte reste fermée
il pourrait réveiller tout le quartier
que ça ne changera rien puisque tu n'es
pas chez toi tu es parti de promener te
bats
baba laddé voilà se mettent à discuter
enfin coûte rapide aux je suis occupée
alors finalement le jeune garçon prend
une récession une résolution sol aller
sans lucio il décide de revenir le
lendemain
le lendemain jour où tu n'es toujours
pas et tu n'es toujours par la loue à
publico le petit garçon toujours lui qui
a vraiment envie de te voir
il a cette idée un kingdom en cris dans
la tête à ça c'est difficile à dire des
fois il a cette idée qui demain ancrée
dans la tête
soli de maçon sans merci de revenir le
surlendemain ça il ne veut pas que j'ai
prise il me va lâcher prise
voilà ça oui alors nous héritons et nous
faisons un peu seule pêche peux tu me
dire les nadon si la sole la sole l'art
qui s'échangent et bah oui des marrons
manche menant rapidement 2 chevaux bat
robin j'arrive rapide de ross l'état
n'est déjà pas parmi les quatre qui
peuplaient que la vie majeur s'est
désisté et rzeszow fait des choses mais
comme jenny batoumi noir ni gros gap et
attention les capucins qui sont
comparativement au lieu dit les quatre
ça me sens heureux car il aime à mai
oui
[Musique]
j'arrive à jouer aujourd'hui et ces
familles vouloir devenir ma famille
[Musique]
ce qui est ma pochette